هذه الحشره تبدو وكانها تتحرك بشكل طبيعي
رغم انها في الحقيقه ميته ولم يتبقى منها
الا الرفاه فما الذي حل بها وكيف تحولت
الى هذا الشكل المرعب انه فطر الزومبي
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منا
عالم غريب
يستهدف الحشرات على وجه الخصوص يلتهم
ضحيته من الداخل ويتغلغل فيها بطريقه
مرعبه فطر كورديسيبس او فطر الزومبي
يستولي على مخي ضحيته بطريقه تجعلها ميته
وحيه في ان معا تماما مثل الزومبي يدفعها
للتحرك نحو بيئه رطبه وقريبه للشمس ما
يسهل نمو الفطر والتغذي على جسم الحشره
الى ان تموت فينفجر الفطر وتنتشر ابواغه
باحثه عن ضحايا جدد لكن ماذا عن البشر هل
يستطيع هذا الفطر تحويلهم الى زومبي
لتتحقق بذلك نبوءه مئات الافلام
والمسلسلات لحسن الحظه فان فطر الزومبي لا
يشكل تحديدا عليهم فادرجه حراره اجسامنا
مرتفعه للغايه بالنسبه له لكي يست ان
يستقر وينمو بشكل جيد كم ان النظام العصبي
للحشرات ابسطوا من نظامنا واجهزتها
المناعيه مختلفه تماما لكن هذا لا يعني ان
البشر في مامن من تهديد انواع اخرى من
الفطريات ليست اقل فتكا بعض الفطريات من
بين ملايين الانواع تقتل نحو واحد فاصله
سبعه مليون شخص سنويا اي حوالي ثلاثه
اضعاف عدد ضحايا الملاريا منظمه الصحه
العالميه حددت 19 نوعا مختلفا من الفطريات
تعتقد انها مصدر قلق كبير منها فطر
كانديدا اوريس الذي يلقب بالفطر القاتل
حيث يتسبب بوفاه نصف الاشخاص الذين يصابون
به على الاقل اضافه الى الفطر الاسود وهو
احد اخطر انواع الفطريات ويلقب باكل لح وم
البشر ويهاجم عاده الوجه والعينين والدماغ
ويمكن ان يكون قاتلا او يترك الناس مشوهين
الى الابد
تشكل الممرضات الفطريه خطرا كبيرا على
الصحه العامه لانها تزداد شيوعا ومقاومه
للعلاج علما انه لا تتاح حاليا سوى اربع
فئات من الادويه المضاده للفطريات وعدد
قليل من الادويه المرشحه قيد تطوير
السريري
الخبراء لا يستبعدون جائحه فطريه قد تتخذ
على الارجح شكلا مختلفا عن جائحه كوفيد من
حيث كيفيه انتشارها ونوع الاشخاص الذين
تصيبهم وجيوش الزومبي البشريه التي
يتخيلها البعض ربما ليست سيناريو واقعيا
لكن الواقعيه ان خطر الفطريات على البشريه
قد يكون اكبر بكثير مما نعتقد